they say the best marriages contain just
a little bit of magic
believe me
I know
hi honey I'm sorry I'm late we had a
whole incident at the warehouse of paint
mixer blew up luckily I had these
overalls in my office I could
oh you're mad aren't you mad
I mean was this the best Valentine's Day
we've ever had no was it the worst yes I
gave you a great gift I tried to
surprise you at the office you repaid
the effort by making a reservation at a
truck stop and dressing up like Tom
Sawyer
but hey maybe this happens to everyone
Claire romance Fizzles magic dies at
least we can mark the exact time it
happened to us thanks to my new watch
which only a switchboard operator from
the 1950s could keep wound
you mean this watch
Houdini handcuffs I've been taking magic
lessons as a Valentine's surprise
wait a minute the supposed hinge
salesman at your office the great
majesto of course I didn't recognize him
without his floor-length robe covered in
question marks and we also really do
have a reservation at that really nice
place down the street so we should
probably get your check excuse me can we
get the check but are you really dressed
beautiful
come on honey we should get going wait
uh do you have the key no
but you do
you know you look prettier now than the
day we got married oh honey and you were
even more handsome I didn't push in the
bathroom
funny you're nice I have always been
nice
I've always been funny wow
for her that could be anyone
Bill and Claire Dunphy
yes Haley honey what is it I'm gonna
what kids I'm just some kids that met at
the pool okay I'm I should go with her
there no you have to learn to let go
turning a family vacation into a
honeymoon takes commitment
you can do it
Eye of the Tiger
I should at least meet them no that is
not
I of the Tiger
what are you wearing what
fighting for your future in front of a
disciplinary committee not entertaining
the Secret Service in Legally Blonde L
won her case because she was treated
herself and dressed cute Haley this is
real life not an excellent movie honey
just put on something else and take down
the makeup why are you guys acting like
this is my fault everybody was drinking
everybody ran I just got caught if
anything I'm the victim here what just
stop just stop talking Haley you're not
the victim here you're the one who
screwed up you made one bad decision
after another now you're about to blow
everything your mother and I worked so
hard to give you and the worst thing is
you don't seem to care we all got up at
3am this morning to bail you out of jail
we haven't eaten a thing and you know
what I haven't heard from you yet I'm
sorry Mom I screwed up Dad please
forgive me now put on some real clothes
we'll see you at the hearing do not be
late come on where are you going to get
that man a waffle
well we shouldn't be talking to you
I'm a married man ah well
I just so happen to like married men
tell me about your wife
of course I well if she's so very
beautiful why are you here with me
because she's always so tired and she's
always making lists of things for me to
do
maybe she did them she wouldn't be so
tired oh no she can make lists for days
go back to your mouth and how sexy it is
I want to go back to these alleged lists
and your nagging wife oh I'm not talking
about you
I didn't mean that can we try this again
so if your wife is so beautiful why are
you here with me
because
I respect her too much
to do to her what I'm going to do to you
I'll be right back
what you're reading in her book yeah
I've been meaning to get to it for a
while oh it's got a map at the beginning
I like it when books do that
did you have an open house this morning
I rescheduled
I thought you might like some company
well the first day of school can be
tough for a stay-at-home moms now you
have to understand the kids are gone the
nest is empty they are rudderless
and a lot of guys wouldn't even notice
but I'm not a lot of guys
I listen with my mind and if you pay
attention women will tell you what they
want by telling you the opposite of what
they want
like the other day Claire was like you
have to move your car there's no space
in the garage for both of our cars and
what she's really saying is that you
know I should probably get a sports car
I'm sort of looking forward to a quiet
day I thought I'd just read Maybe
go for a run later that's it great we'll
run together
do that
I know
listening
thing is I like to run alone and I run
kind of fast so so so
I'm not sure you're gonna be able to
keep up with me
you're kidding right no you really think
I can't keep up with you I'm not sure
you can keep up with this conversation I
think you're forgetting that I power
walk every morning and that I wear my
special shoes with the big soles which
were designed by a doctor
yes I know but I run
every day you really think you can run
as fast as me no Phil I think I can run
much much faster
than you
boom just like that the whole day
changed it was game on she knew it I
knew it we both knew it
Juliana wait honestly it is one minute
to 12 Phil valentine's day is over not
quite
I can't see you anymore
what I can't believe I'm saying this
because you're the most intoxicating
woman a man could ever meet
but by some Cosmic miracle there's a
woman in that house that I still find is
sexy and exciting as the first day I met
her
I should probably let her know that more
often than I do that's my bad
but point is a guy like me gets that
lucky he quits while he's ahead
it sounds to me like she's the lucky one
goodbye Juliana
[Music]
where are you going sorry don't don't
beg it's beneath you
but please go my wife will see you
go go away make this harder than it is
okay
Juliana no Phil
really
[Laughter]
oh no I'm in heaven no no you're not not
yet you made it and changes so you know
surgery bear was here and scrubbed him
for the whole procedure
that's very dangerous he's a women's
studies professor
besides the only thing I really needed
was my neck pillow
I knew if he didn't have something to
keep you busy you'd worry all day oh
honey you really do know me
I think I just expected a little too
much from this vacation you were so
sweet to try that was dumb
like you said The Thrill Is Gone I never
said that no that's over
but wait
put a few seconds back on the clock
the kid still has a few moves oh my God
I figured out why we couldn't have a
honeymoon
because we never had a wedding oh my God
I still can't tell if you think this is
lame we're cool
[Music]
looks like I finally get to walk you
down the aisle
you better want me okay
we had today to celebrate the renewing
of the marriage vows of Phil and Claire
on this day they've chosen to reaffirm
their love for each other
and kiss your bride
I present to you still his husband and
wife Mr Mrs Dunford
foreign